make way for the captain they're easy
boats where's captain Alden hey here son
Gator captain's dead went down with his
ship XO no longer with us ma'am
all this happened in the crash yes sir
so who has the Conn Gator is the
highest-ranking officer on board I
believe you do sir destroy your tigress
is docking a shuttle to come aboard
Roger that you spin in radar still
turning sir scream get Raven transport
set for evac I want our casualties
outbound right away drop officer
coordinate with engineer and get us
mobile Roger engineer McCollum is on how
we staff sergeant come on count on your
help you love what you need from me
left's in it salt you with me always
Gator get the Admiral on the line copy
comms officer Stratcom topcat sovereign
Roger Tigers captain on deck captain
ferron lieutenant who's in charge
lieutenant Reyes scart team leader
captain your ship and crew in tucked sir
Admiral Raines is on the line put him
through captain Farrell ladies gentlemen
it's good to see you sir let me make our
situation absolutely clear we are now at
war with the settlement defense from due
to Captain alders use of force the enemy
was driven into retreat at this time
divers and retribution are the only
operable ships we have our course of
action moving forward is to by earth
time while we rebuild our fleet
understood Admiral tigress is prepared
for tasking today's attack was not
limited to Geneva set def launched a
concurrent strike on the moon gateway
port and those cargo terminals received
Freight critical to rebuilding our fleet
so your mission is to retake that port
lieutenant Reyes
I'm promoting you to the rank of
commander you are now the acting captain
of retribution Roger that Admiral keep
the enemy away from home Godspeed
captain's Tomcat out you got no heroin
go without it i sell-- we do things in
the infantry leftenant will insert the
Marines from retribution I'll provide
overwatch from tigress let's go to work
captain Reyes stay sharp out there all
of you you too captain you got some
shoes to fill now captain we've got
limited boots and guns lieutenant Salter
and I will deploy with you this is a
ground assault captain's places on the
bridge not this captain about today
pre-order and get the terminal bonus map